if your hair is flat at the front then
you need to give this hack a go take the
front section on one side twist it
around your finger and then secure it in
place with a hair grip or a slide of
some sort then repeat on the other side
I obviously went a little bit wrong here
there we go she's got the hang of it now
twist it around and pop a slide in she
looks great okay now take your hair
spray give each side a bit of a spritz
without getting it in your eyes then
take your hair dryer use the cold shot
setting to blow dry each side okay
moment of
truth I mean it doesn't look quite like
it did on Tik Tok but the volume it's
giving is good it definitely looks a bit
bouncier than it did before let me know
what you think